Recently,
there's been a lot of talk about measles.
What does measles actually do and shit,
you vaccinate against it
or is this just hysteria?
Measles is a virus,
a Holler of proteins,
RNA plus some more proteins
for reproduction. It
cannot reproduce by itself.
It needs a host cell. To do
so. To understand measles,
we have to understand the immune system.
You might already have seen the visual
system we developed to help here.
Now let's focus on the parts of the
immune system relevant to me. Source,
the measles virus enters humans
through the nose, mouth, or eyes.
The measles infection starts in the lungs.
Measles is especially good at infecting
the body's first line of defense.
Macrophages, powerful for God. Cells
that protect the lungs from intruders.
They enter a cell and take it over.
The virus reprograms the cell and
transforms it into a dangerous virus
production center.
Once a cell is filled with viruses,
they leave the crippled cell
and begin the cycle over again.
But the immune system has powerful
weapons against virus infections,
natural killer cells.
These cells basically patrol the body
and check other cells for infections.
If they find an infected cell,
they order it to commit suicide.
This is sill effective that
for the first 10 days or so,
you will not even notice the
you're infected with measles.
And now the reason why
measles is so powerful.
After a period of fighting and dying,
macrophages alert the brain of the
immune system, the dendritic cells,
the job of the dendritic cells is
to collect samples of intruders,
traveled to the lymph nodes,
and then activate the heavy weapons that
eradicate the infection very fast in a
team effort. But the measles
virus uses a dreadful tactic.
It infects the dendritic cells and uses
them as a Trojan horse to enter deeper
into the body.
The infected cells travel to the next
lymph node to alert other immune cells.
Once it arrives,
the measles virus spreads around the
virgin t and B cells and infects the hub.
It attacks the very system
that evolve to fight it.
Now things happen very fast.
The lymph system spreads the virus
everywhere and it enters the bloodstream
infecting cells while traveling.
Measles infects organs like the spleen,
the liver, the intestines, and
most importantly the lungs.
The symptoms range from a very high
fever, headache, sickness, bronchitis,
and of course a rash in the lungs.
The immune system was doing pretty okay,
but now millions of viruses attack a
second time and killed countless cells
wiping out the defense systems.
In this phase,
you start coughing out
millions of measles viruses.
Measles is so contagious at this stage
that if you meet someone who isn't
vaccinated,
there's about a 90% chance you'll infect
them without the protective army in the
lungs,
other bacteria or viruses that would
usually not stand a chance can now enter
the lungs and developing
harmful paralleled infections
that can cause pneumonia.
The most common way to die from measles,
your body's immune system
is now seriously wounded.
Various protective systems
are hurt and disrupted.
The virus spreads everywhere in
affecting the skin all over the body.
The typical measles rash
now becomes visible and in
some cases the measles virus
reaches the brain and
causes a brain infection.
If it does so the chances of dying
are between 20 to 40% and there may be
longterm damage,
but your body is far from giving up
at their stage and it fights back
aggressively.
Some dendritic cells that survive long
enough to activate the antivirus forces
of the body plasma cells in the lymph
nodes start producing billions of
antibodies,
tiny proteins that mark can affect
itself for destruction or clump the virus
together.
Killer t cells flood the body and kill
infected cells left and right after two
to three weeks,
the body usually gets the upper
hand and overwhelmed the infection,
but the [inaudible] system has now
seriously weakened and may take weeks or
months to recover, leaving the
body vulnerable to other diseases.
But if you make it,
you are now immune.
The immune system remembers the
virus forever. Measles is no joke.
Although 84% of all humans are
vaccinated against measles,
122,000 people died because of the
infection in 2014 some people cannot get
vaccinations by that because they're too
young because of chemotherapy or HIV or
because they're allergic to the vaccine.
They need the rest of us to
stop the disease for them.
The measles vaccination is
safe, cheap, and available.
There are no benefits from
having measles at all.
You don't strengthen your immune
system and it's not more natural.
Most people who don't vaccinate only
want the best for their children,
which is honorable,
but if you ask yourself,
am I putting the life of my child and
other children at risk by not vaccinating
against measles? The sad
answer is yes. Yes you are.
Let's not play the blame game though.
Let's work together and
eradicate this virus together.
We can get rid of these dreadful monsters
and consign them to their rightful
place.
The history books.